combien combien vous gagnez par mois en
travaillant autant c'est vraiment très
très variable d'un mois à l'autre quoi
ça jamais versé plus quoi donc maximum
1000 euros
pour toute l'Italie sur le site de
Pompéi datant de 2000 ans une fresque
montre un plat qui ressemble à s'il est
prendre à une pizza ruine pizza la
nature morte a été découverte lors de
fouilles sur les parois d'une maison de
la célèbre cité romaine de formerons de
le plat est agrémenté de fruits et même
d'épices qui seraient représentés par
des points de couleur jaunâtre et
ocre donc on est magique l'Observatoire
napolitaine on vient maintenant négocie
je vous passe les débats en Italie
est-ce que c'est vraiment une pizza s'il
y a pas de sauce tomate ni de mozzarella
vous avez 4 heures est-ce que vous
arrivez quand même à vous divertir à
vous amuser quand même à partir de temps
en temps on va quand c'était quand la
dernière fois que vous êtes partis il y
a 2 ans non
4 jours de vacances en deux ans
et pour beaucoup se montrer en maillot
de bain et souvent une épreuve surtout
pour les françaises dans un récent
sondage 67% des femmes se disent gênée à
l'idée d'être partiellement dévêtue sur
la plage 39% chez les hommes pour cette
psychologue cette différence s'explique
par la pression sociale que subissent
les corps féminins
comme autre passion la culture italienne
donc vous trichez
je vous promets que je regarde pas sous
votre jupe parce que attendez je vais
mettre là parce que là je suis pile en
face de vous on n'a pas encore vraiment
cette intimité là et vous avez vu la
partie vitrée au sol qui donne sur la
cuisine hyper sympa très moderne ça
apporte la lumière de l'étage jusqu'à la
cuisine après faut pas être en chemise
de nuit avec les noisettes à l'air parce
que sinon on vous voit pardon autre
chose qu'on peut faire également c'est
le relevé de buste le relevé de bus
c'est on est assis sur les fesses on
relève son tronc voilà et même chose on
essaye de tenir là on va mesurer la
durée des abdominaux
on n'a pas besoin d'être mince à
l'approche de l'été on n'a pas besoin
d'être parfaitement épilé de ne pas
avoir de cellulite franchement moi
j'essaye de montrer que les corps au
naturel sont tous très beaux ces
conseils accepter son corps comme il
aime mais aussi se méfier des photos
parfaites que l'on peut admirer sur
Instagram ou Tik Tok je leur dis surtout
ne vous comparez pas à ça parce que
c'est pas la réalité alors tu as bien
dormi un train laisse tomber
cred je sens plus les gens là je bon à
rien
[Musique]
ça va être une belle journée le Superman
cette fois-ci on est sur le ventre on
lève les bras on lève les jambes et là
voilà tel qu'on le voit là et là aussi
c'est c'est super ça permet de mesurer
également la qualité qui a au niveau du
dos mais super non mais Julien
en subito cette pression du regard des
autres mais il y a des bonnes nouvelles
quelque part dans sondage quand on
compare à 2017 la dernière fois que mifa
avait posé la même question aux Français
la pression c'est un peu relâché sur
certains points par exemple 61% des
Françaises disent avoir fait un régime
en vue de cet été c'est 7 points de
moins qu'en 2017 58% ont fait de la gym
14 points de moins qu'en 2017 bref on
fait moins d'efforts en vue de la
fameuse séquence du maillot de bain sur
la plage après un passage obligé sous la
jupe de Marilyn à pamsprings
bon j'ai vérifié elle a une culotte on a
fait une sorte
tu es sérieux mec tout sourire presque
fier de son geste ce touriste a priori
américain et pourtant rechercher dans
toute l'Italie son délit avoir gravé son
nom et celui de sa copine sur le Colisée
à Rome ce grand amphithéâtre vieux de
plus de 2000 ans et inscrit au
patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO un acte
en apparence romantique qui pourrait lui
valoir 5 ans de prison sur Twitter le
ministre italien de la culture s'est
indigné ce n'est pas la première fois
que des touristes dégradent ce monument
le i il n'a pas inventé l'eau chaude le
pauvre
imbécile oui vous pouvez m'appeler
Olivier le premier coup c'est pour
l'avant
et le second c'est pour l'arrière
ça
va lui
accrochez-vous on va passer sur trois
roues
on est sur trois roues
[Rires]
petit animal nyctalope c'est un animal
qui a des aigrettes les coquines
et donc du coup il nous sort nyctalope
expression
[Musique]
merci beaucoup de nous avoir escorté
avec tes potes motards en fait le luxe
est un peu comme un biker
marseillais se sont tellement à l'aise
sur son rocher qu'à la fin de son JT
s'est lancé dans un édito venu de
l'espace je rappelle que c'est un
journal
voilà c'est terminé pour notre édition
Marseille c'est difficile de discuter
musique avec les jeunes parce que
franchement ils y comprennent rien à
part vous jouez dans la vie il y a aussi
la musique la belle musique le jazz le
jazz la quintessence du jazz
moi c'est Marseille bébé c'est tout et
un enfant et pour notre prochain voyage
j'aurais quand même de rencontrer pour
la première fois
tu sais
c'est une question
évidemment je te suis Lulu je te suis
partout
on avance de galère en galère et puis de
plaisir au plaisir ça fait partie aussi
de la vie et je pense que
c'est un bon résumé de la vie en général
le président de la République pourra
donner tous les milliards qui veut faire
tous les plans le 2 le 4 ça changera
rien qu'est-ce que vous voulez
gagner la Coupe du Monde
monsieur le Président je sais pas moi
allez rester avec nous pour la suite de
l'actualité
je pense que quand j'aurai fini ces
émissions j'irai faire une thérapie
quand même